allez vous comme chaque mardi Véronique
je me tourne vers vous on va présenter
les informations insolites du
département des Yvelines on va commencer
d'ailleurs tout de suite par une
initiative de la mairie de
Triel-sur-Seine qui propose aux femmes
des stages de self-défense exactement
alors j'ai trouvé cette information
passionnante dans Le Parisien et donc à
Triel-sur-Seine il n'y a pas plus de
violence qu'ailleurs c'est juste pareil
sauf que un des élus un élu de la
municipalité et l'élu à la sécurité et
professeur d'art martial martiaux
martial bref et il a eu lui-même cette
idée donc de proposer aux femmes deux
heures de cours par mois le dimanche
matin gratuit on peut y aller à partir
de 15 ans et on vous explique certaines
clés pour savoir se défendre en cas
d'agression alors tous ces
renseignements c'est David désiré le
chef de service de la police municipale
qui me les a gentiment donné alors déjà
on apprend en quelques mots si possible
évitez l'agression il y a quelque chose
a déjà être attentif ne pas avoir un
casque sur les oreilles être un peu
ouvert à son environnement ne pas être
les yeux rivés sur le smartphone ou même
changer de chemin pas prendre toujours
le même chemin ne pas hésiter à fuir
quand on sent quelque chose on bref si
malheureusement on en arrive à
l'agression comment rester debout
essayez d'apaiser la situation enfin
facile à dire dialoguer si possible ou
si ça me fait un peu rire c'est pas
drôle mais si vous arrivez par bonheur à
faire tomber l'agresseur n'attendez pas
qu'il se relève ça va pas trop mal non
on s'en va
toutes les informations il y a une
inscription qui est obligatoire en
aléatoire qui s'affiche en va continuer
avec un livre ou un projet de livre
écrit en hommage à André Moret alors
André Moret les gens ne savent pas
forcément qui c'est ce fut un maître
berger qui a exercé son métier à la
bergerie de Rambouillet en 1935 entre
1935 et 1970 et qui incarne à la fois
tradition côté innovateur de ce lieu
formidable qui est la Bergerie Nationale
de Rambouillet complètement alors c'est
pas très sangot qui est un homme
passionné par l'agriculture le monde
rural l'agriculture propre saine
respectueuse qui a d'ailleurs créé un
musée agricole à l'intérieur de la
bergerie de Rambouillet et qui a eu
l'idée d'écrire ce livre en hommage à
André Mory qui est un maître berger
alors moi comme d'hab j'ai 1929 1970 peu
importe il a eu un troupeau de 650 tête
alors le matin il se levé à 4h il allait
s'occuper des bêtes et après il
enseignait l'art du d'être berger et ce
n'est pas rien voilà
c'est un livre donc qui est bourré
d'anecdotes
Patrice Angot l'a fait avec l'aide de
Philippe Moret le fils d'André Le Maître
berger on y apprend plein de choses il y
a des archives incroyables inédites des
photos
de Gaulle est venu le voir André Moret
plein de réparties lui a dit je préfère
garder mon troupeau que le vôtre la
femme de René Coty aller chercher ses
fromages enfin il y a tout un tas de
d'anecdotes passionnantes il était très
fort en généalogie pour les mérinos
voilà il faisait attention à la
consanguinité et alors le mérinos c'est
la meilleure laine qui existe ça je ne
vous apprends rien quand il fait chaud
vous avez un peu frais et quand il fait
froid vous avez chaud on ne le quitte
pas sur mérinos voilà en souscription on
le précise
si on veut aider la parution de ce livre
on termine avec un verset de coeur
hauteur d'ailleurs du Dictionnaire
amoureux de Versailles c'est Franck
Ferrand tu prends la tête de la cité de
l'histoire c'est quoi cette cité de
l'histoire alors déjà Franck Ferrand oui
comme vous dites dictionnaire amoureux
de Versailles voilà ça c'est la preuve
c'est un amoureux de Versailles de cœur
et d'armes on peut pas faire mieux il a
même habité Versailles il est historien
il est sur les ondes de Radio Classique
il est à la télévision et là il est
endossé un nouveau job il est presque il
est pas président pardon il est
directeur de la cité de l'histoire c'est
quoi cette histoire alors là c'était de
l'histoire elle est à la défense elle
vient de d'ouvrir aujourd'hui c'est un
projet qui existe depuis 18 mois qui a
été conçu en un an avec 400 intervenants
et certains ont travaillé jour et nuit
et Franck Ferrand notre ami historien
sur les ondes de Radio Classique à la
télévision on est le directeur voilà et
le but de cette énorme lieu c'est de
vous permettre de vous immerger alors
c'est la grande mode en ce moment
l'immersion parle que ça et là vraiment
immersion totale dans la réalité
virtuelle voilà 12 siècles d'histoire
vous avez avoir des pièces avec des
comédiens vous allez plonger dans des
époques particulières vous allez avoir
tout un une scénographie autour de
Victor Hugo vous allez pouvoir visiter
Notre-Dame comme si vous y étiez de
plusieurs points de vue
enfin bref c'est il y aura des
conférences qui vont changer
régulièrement il y a une librairie un
restaurant face à un endroit où on peut
aller plusieurs fois et une frise
chronologique géante avec des bornes
interactives on pourra appuyer sur les
dates qui vous intéressent plus ou moins
enfin un truc de dingue
très futuriste et en même temps parlant
de d'époque très très anciennes voilà ce
futur grâce à la technologie on revient
on revient dans le dans le passé voilà
j'en tousse
merci c'est ainsi
qu'on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour d'autres idées insolites d'autres
informations